Scre4m welcomed us back to Woodsboro High School,
it doesn’t look exactly the same, but this could
technically be a different entrance, and this
could just be a different part of the building.
But one aspect that is definitely a new addition,
which you might have missed, is this bust,
dedicated to the late Principal Arthur Himbry,
who was one of the victims in Scream 1.
Here’s a little bit of a better
look from a behind the scenes photo.
For other references you might not
have noticed, like the movie props
featured in the background of Stab-a-thon,
stick around to the end of this video.
This video is sponsored by NordVPN
(metal music)
Welcome to Things You Missed. I am ‘Don’t
Look At My Tits I Have A Mind Morris,’ and
if you remembered that reference, it probably
hasn’t been long since you last watched Scre4m. And
I actually think this is one of the most
warranted examples putting a number in
the title in place of a letter. In a movie like
Se7en, or Thir13n Ghosts, there’s no real reason
for it other than style. But since this movie
serves as a satire of horror movie remakes,
most of which have the same title as the
original, inserting the number 4 allows
you to read it as just Scream, while still
differentiating that this is the fourth movie.
Which makes it all the more disappointing that
they didn’t follow suit with Scream (2022) by
calling it 5cream. Let’s get in to the Things
You Missed.
(menacing music)
Being a remake, this one opens exactly the
same way the original did, with a teen girl
receiving a phone call. Sherrie and
Trudie are trying to pick a movie,
and we see the blue screen on the TV, something I
talked about when I covered the original Scream,
which represents the idea that a movie is
about to begin, not only for us, the audience,
but also the characters, who are somewhat
aware that they are living through a movie.
However, this is the first movie to take
place well after the others, it’s set in 2010,
so the new horror reference points for the young
characters are noughties horror like Saw and Final
Destination. Saw in particular seems to have the
biggest influence on Scream 4. It’s the movie that
Sherrie chooses for movie night, and the color
grade takes after the Saw look. For example,
look at the first outdoor scene, and how the bloom
resembles the look of the Public Execution Trap
from Saw 7. Or for a better idea of exactly how the
look of this movie differs from the previous ones,
try comparing the Stab footage from
Scream 2 to that of the fourth movie.
There are also a few scenes that seem to have
Saw’s imprint on them. Olivia encounters her
masked attacker hiding in her closet, just like
Adam from Saw. Rebecca is ambushed in an empty
parking garage, just like Dr. Gordon from Saw.
One of the side characters is Robbie Mercer,
who is played by Erik Knudsen; he was Daniel
Matthews in Saw 2, and both of them know a lot
about cameras. Stab is now a seven movie series,
just like Saw was at the time. Stab-a-thon is
held in an abandoned barn. This was well before
Jigsaw, the Saw movie set in an abandoned barn,
but Gale’s coming across this creepy pig head next
to these rusty gears still looks like something
right out of the original Saw saga, or as some
of you suggested on my Saw videos, the Saw-ga.
The opening of Scre4m also serves
as a mission statement about what
we should expect for this movie. And
that is, to expect the unexpected.
– [Charlie] The unexpected is the new cliche. Modern
audiences get savvy to the rules of the originals.
So the reverse has become the new standard.
– The intro does this with it’s false
openings. First we see two girls get killed;
turns out that’s just Stab 6. Then we get some
meta-cinema commentary from our new characters…
– It’s all so predictable, there’s no element of
surprise, you can see everything coming! (stab)
–  …but that just turns out to be Stab 7. So
we’re seeing first hand how filmmakers are
now actively trying to do what the audience
doesn’t expect in the decade since Stab 3.
And this, of course, also applies
to our movie, Scream 4. Scre4m.
So after those two false intros,
we meet our real intro characters,
Marnie Cooper and Jenny Randall. Marnie does
share a last name with Cici Cooper from Scream 2,
but they probably aren’t related -- despite
their shared eye and hair color. I’m actually
more interested in her first name, Marnie,
because it brings to mind the 1964 Alfred
Hitchcock film. Being one of the most
important figures in the horror genre,
Hitchcock has already been the subject of several
homages in the Scream franchise, like Billy Loomis
sharing a name with Sam Loomis from Psycho, the
shower shot from Psycho being in Stab, and one of
the actresses in Scream 3 incorrectly identifying
it as a reference to Vertigo, among others.
In the classroom where Cinema Club is held, you
can spot a Vertigo poster. On the chalkboard,
there’s a lesson about the plot structure of
Hitchcock’s Rear Window, and Kirby’s room has
a Rear Window poster as well. Marnie may not
be the only Hitchcock namesake. Sidney has a
publicist named Rebecca, which could be an homage
to Hitchcock’s 1940 film Rebecca, and the police
officer, Perkins, is actually named Anthony
Perkins, we hear his partner call him that.
– Anthony! Perkins!
– [Zac] Anthony Perkins is the actor who
played Norman Bates in Psycho. The
rest of the intro sequence features a lot
of fun homages to the Scream franchise,
like Ghostface trying to tell Jenny to
think of him as her director.
– [Caller] You’re in my
movie. You’ve got a fun part! So don't blow it.
– [Zac] The last villain literally was
the director of Stab 3. Marnie
is sent crashing through the glass
door a la Steve Orth from Scream.
– [Caller] But you? You’re the dumb blond with the big
tits. We’ll have some fun with you before you die.
– And just like Sidney predicted in the
first Scream, she makes the mistake
of running up the stairs rather than out
the door. She ends up going to the attic,
like Sidney did while trying to escape Ghostface
at Stu’s house, and then eventually to the garage,
where her escape is foiled by the
garage door, just like Tatum in Scream.
Dewey is woken up by his ringtone.
(80s techno)
The song is Axel F, from the soundtrack of
Beverly Hills Cop. And Dewey is also a cop again,
he’s not the Sheriff of Woodsboro. Also of
note, this song has been remade many times,
by the likes of TechnoCop,
Clock, and yes… Crazy Frog.
– Ding. Ding.
– [Zac] Soon we meet the next generation
of Woodsboro High School students.
It seems that Kirby knows who the killer is
without actually knowing who the killer is.
– Before you get in the car, you
have to promise not to kill me.
– There’s a similar foreshadowing moment
like this later when Officer Hoss is doing
a crossword puzzle and asks Perkins
for a four letter word for courage.
– [Perkins] Uhh… Guts.
– It would not be long after that when Olivia’s
guts would be ripped out by Ghostface. The
event is also foreshadowed by these chinese
take-out boxes that have a red splatter design.
But before we get there, we would check
in on the current state of Gale Riley,
whose office plays host to a
few more Things You Missed.
As the new Sheriff of the town, Deputy
Dewey Riley oversees everything that
happens in Woodsboro. But can he see
why kids love Nord VPN? *coughing fit*
The speeds are blazing fast! Want to see me
connect to Nord VPN? Want to see me do it again?
It's easy to use. Connect with 1-click or
just set up auto connect so you're always
protected. With Nord VPN, 3rd parties will
not be able to spy on your online activity.
Even your internet service provider
and your government will have no idea
if you illegally streamed that new movie
or not. Cause it's none of their business!
You want more content? Let's talk about
content. Nord's got over 5400 servers in
60 countries. Meaning you can change
your virtual location and access way
more movies and shows. For example, Scream
4 isn't available on Netflix in my country,
but if I just click on this United Kingdom
server... the Brits got the hookup!
At just over $3 per month, I don't know why you
wouldn't get Nord. For the cost of a beverage,
you too can have that peace of mind when browsing
the web by clicking the link in the description,
NordVPN dot com slash czsworld vpn. But wait!
When you use my link you also get one month
free and a 30-day money back guarantee. So you have no reason not to go try it. Click
the link in the description to get started.
(mysterious music)
Each new character in the fourth installment
of Scream is a spiritual successor to one of
the characters from the original Scream. Which
is why it’s a satire of horror movie remakes.
Like a remake you have new actors playing
old roles. Jill is the new Sidney Prescott,
a high school student thrust into danger due
to the attack of her family member. Trevor is
Billy Loomis, the boyfriend who becomes a major
suspect. Kirby is Randy Meeks, the biggest horror film
buff of the friend group and walking knowledge
database. Olivia is Tatum Riley, the attractive
popular girl who dies way too early. Charlie is
Stu Macher, the easily peer pressured friend.
Robbie Mercer is Kenny, the camera guy.
And Rebecca is Gale Weathers, the media.
She even makes the comparison between Dewey and
Barney Fife, just like Gale did back in Scream 2.
– [Dewey] Page 32. Deputy Dewey filled the
room with his Barney Fife-ish presence.
– [Rebecca] Just wait, Barney
Fife, I’m running an event here.
– Speaking of Gale, she’s now writing a work
of fiction, after penning the book trilogy
that became the basis for the Stab movies, and we
can see them right here: The Woodsboro Murders,
College Terror and Hollywood Horror. It seems that
she also wrote other stories about a Ghostface
killer because there’s this additional book,
Ghostface Returns, which we get a better look
at later in Jill’s room. This is probably the
basis of the fictional Stab movies 4 through 7.
After news that the killings have started again
breaks, we see the Woodsboro police station, and
if you pause, you can see the KQIS 6 van whirring
by in the foreground. This is the same station
that Gale worked for back in Scream 1, where
the van was parked outside during Stu Macher’s
party. We also see the channel 6 microphone
appear a couple times throughout the movie.
Rebecca is celebrating the news of the two girls
being butchered, and she calls it a payday. The
media sensationalizing the crimes has been a
theme that has run through each of the Scream
movies so far. In the first and second films
it’s the TV news media, in the third it’s the
Hollywood film industry and now we’re seeing it
happen in publishing. There would also be another
angle to this present in Scream 4: social
media. Robbie gets involved as essentially
what we would now call the IRL streamer, and
the killers are recording all their kills,
which Jill plans to use to help frame Trevor
and Charlie and anticipates that the footage
will go viral and garner her more attention.
However, she fails, so this part never pans out.
Later in the movie, Rebecca tries to
convince Sidney to sign a new book deal.
– You’re a victim. For life. So embrace it!
– And this is another aspect of the social
commentary about the media. Rebecca doesn't
understand the point of Sidney's book, it's
about her journey to no longer be the victim.
Jill, on the other hand, is on
a journey to become the victim.
– How do you think people become famous
anymore? You don’t have to achieve anything.
You just gotta have f*cked up sh*t happen to you.
– She's an extreme example of someone with
what we would now call victim mentality.
Like the original Scream's social commentary
about sensationalizing violence in the news,
and Scream 3's commentary about inappropriate
relations in Hollywood, Scre4m's take on victim
mentality has only become more relevant over
the years as more and more people try to invent
a scenario where they are perceived as having
been wronged, with the intention of going viral.
The "my experience with ____"
trope on social media has become
as cliche as the slasher movies
that Randy idolized in Scream.
– He had me unfollow all of them, which to
me was really weird, and I didn’t like it.
– But anyway, when Rebecca meets Gale, Gale
tells her that she is Gale Riley now;
she’s been married to Dewey for 10
years, to which Rebecca is surprised.
– It always seemed like more of
a movie romance than a real one
because it was a movie. And in real
life you two would never be… ooh!
– In my Scream 3 video, I mentioned that Dewey
and Gale’s marriage was one of the many plot
elements inspired by real life, because David
Arquette and Courtney Cox actually got married.
Now they had actually been married 10 years
and, like in the movie, their relationship
was in trouble. They separated in real life
in 2010, the same year this movie is set.
The trouble in the on-screen marriage is
exemplified that evening at the house,
in a line that also serves as another callback
to that Dewey and Gale scene from Scream 2.
This time instead of Dewey quoting
a specific page from Gale’s book,
he’s quoting Sidney’s book
in regards to his marriage.
– Just when you think things can’t get any
worse, sometimes they don’t. Sometimes they get better.
Out of Darkness by Sidney Prescott, page 220.
– Later in the evening, after Ghostface comes
for Olivia, Sidney tries to get into The
Morris Household to save her, and she does so
by throwing a potted plant through the window.
Sidney has always been seen as the slasher
successor to Laurie Strode from Halloween,
with her story even running
parallel to Laurie’s in Scream 1,
and now we’ve got her throwing a potted
plant at a house, like Laurie in Halloween.
As always, the movie is packed with
Halloween references. When Sidney
makes a guest appearance at the
Cinema Club, Robbie hypes up her
presence by comparing her to the actresses
who starred in Halloween and The Exorcist.
– [Robbie] Beyond Jamie Lee Curtis,
forget Linda Blair, this is the ultimate.
– Which is also its own kind of joke because
they both appear in Scream 1. The cinema club
holds their party, Stab-a-thon, at an abandoned
farm house, much like the party in Halloween 5.
But if you look closer, there’s a for sale
sign outside the farm that says Roberts
Reality. Roberts refers to Sidney’s mom’s
side of the family. Her mother was Maureen
Roberts before getting married, and Sidney’s
aunt is Kate Roberts. She is the realtor that
this sign is referring to. Earlier drafts of
the script make mention of her profession.
Kate takes Sidney in while she’s back in
Woodsboro. We can assume that Sidney’s dad
moved away or died, because he’s not in the
movie. So Sidney is staying with a realtor,
who happens to be selling the
location of “Stab-a-thon”.
And this is another similarity she has to Laurie
Strode, who, after losing her parents is taken
in by the Strode family, and her new adoptive
father is a realtor who is selling a house,
the Myers House, which was the location
of more of a literal Stab-a-thon.
With Sidney being part of the older generation
now, she takes responsibility for the kids’
safety. Towards the end, she instructs Jill to
hide under a bed and then makes it look as if
she’s helped her escape off the balcony. This is
very similar to Laurie’s strategy in Halloween.
Of course, there’s one line where Sid is made out
to look more less like Laurie
and more like her brother…
– You just won’t die will you? Who
are you? Michael f*cking Myers?
– The last Halloween reference I want
to bring up is this poster seen in
the classroom where Cinema Club is held.
If you’ve seen Rob Zombie’s Halloween 2,
you know it is not a remake of Halloween 2. Rob
Zombie’s Halloween 1 is a remake of the original
Halloween, however Rob Zombie’s Halloween
2 goes off in it’s own… strange direction.
I’m guessing this was likely a hint about what
the plans were for the Scream franchise. In
January 2010, screenwriter Kevin Williamson,
who had returned after an absence in Scream 3,
stated that he was contracted to
make Scream 4 and Scream 5. However,
the fourth movie underperformed at the box
office, director Wes Craven got brain cancer,
and the fifth installment had to be put on
the shelf. Save that one for a rainy decade.
But as long as we’re talking
about the meta of Scre4m,
I’ve also gotta mention what is perhaps
the most meta thing in the whole franchise.
(melancholy music)
Remember that cop character, Anthony Perkins?
Well not only is he named after a Psycho actor,
but he also appeared in Scary Movie 3. Scary Movie
is a parody of Scream and Scream
is a satire of the horror genre.
If you’ve kept up with my Scream Things You
Missed series, you already know that the first
Scream contained many references to slasher
movies, including Wes Craven’s own work. So
Scream 4 focuses on movies that were remade.
The new version of the video store scene is
the Cinema Club scene where we see a whole bunch
of movie posters, like this one: The Hills Have
Eyes. This checks both boxes, it was directed
by Wes Craven and it received a remake in 2006.
If you’re really paying attention
you’ll also notice the poster for The People Under The Stairs,
a 1991 Wes
Craven production. Before his death,
Craven planned to remake this,
but never quite got around to it.
There’s also a poster for George Romero’s
Dawn of the Dead. It was remade in 2004.
The Thing is a remake of The Thing From
Another World from 1951. You may notice
the poster on the left is not a horror movie,
it’s a film called Zack and Miri Make a Porno.
This is actually a continuation of a series
of easter eggs between Wes Craven and Kevin
Smith. I talked about this in greater detail
in my Scream 3 episode, but the two directors
have been exchanging cameos and easter eggs
in their movies since the original Scream.
If you look around the classroom,
you’ll also see that the Cinema
Club are big fans of the Stab franchise.
You can see the Stab poster right here,
and the Stab 3 poster back in the corner. An
interesting note here is the tagline for Stab
3 is “Hollywood Horror”. Which means this is not
the same movie we saw being shot in Scream 3,
whose tagline was “Return To Woodsboro.” It
seems that since all the cast was killed,
the studio decided to make Stab 3 about
that, rather than trying to recast for
Return To Woodsboro. Little did they know, the
story would return to Woodsboro all on its own.
Behind this shelf is the Stab 5 poster,
and the Stab 6 poster. But that’s really
only just the beginning of the display of
their Stab fandom. We see much more that
night at Stab-a-thon where there are a lot
of background details you may have missed.
Here’s a girl dressed as Casey Becker, posing
with a decoration of the “gutted” Casey Becker,
which you can see more of behind the crowd
right here. Another display shows Tatum
Riley hanging out of the garage flap. Many of
the attendees are wearing costumes of Scream
and Stab characters. Something that is very
accurate if you’ve ever been to a screening.
These two guys in the audience are both
dressed as Dewey, and one of them even has
a mustache hat. There’s another Casey
Becker on the left. A lot of the kids
have Woodsboro High letterman jackets, like
Casey’s boyfriend Steve Orth, but then again,
those are also their actual high school jackets,
so I won’t count that one. But I will count this
couple dressed as Gale and Dewey, Gale in her
green news dress and Dewey in his uniform.
– [Gale] This party is all about the Stab
movies, come on! How meta can you get?
– [Dewey] How what-a can you get?
– [Gale] I don’t know, I heard him say it.`
– Gale places cameras around the party much
like she did in Scream, so that she can
watch from her vehicle. In fact, one of the
cameras is right beneath the movie screen,
just as the surveillance camera in
Scream was placed under Stu’s television.
Now you’re probably wondering: are there
differences between the version of Stab we saw
in Scream 2 and what we see in Scream 4? So I cut
both films apart and lined them both up, and the
answer is: yes there are a lot of differences.
Enough to make a whole video about it, which
I plan on doing. But for this video, I’m only
gonna talk about the ones that are interesting.
In Scream 4 we see this card at the
beginning: A Robert Rodriguez Film.
This sort-of qualifies as a
crew reference easter egg,
because Robert Rodriguez was brought in
to film the Stab footage for Scream 2.
After lining up all the cut points, there’s an
interesting synchronization that occurs. Which
is that Gale gets stabbed at the same time as
Casey in Stab, which in Scream 2, occurred at the
same time Maureen was stabbed inside the movie
theater. Just thought that was kind of cool.
Before being attacked, Gale holds her
camera by her waist, looking behind her,
unintentionally recreating the moment from Scream
where the characters in the news van
see Ghostface sneaking up behind Randy.
– Behind you kid!
– Randy!
– This time it’s Dewey, concerned about Gale.
– Gale! Gale behind you!
– This is more than just a nostalgic callback
though, it also sets up a scene later where
Robbie puts his headset on backwards. We’re
expecting Ghostface to appear behind him,
so it’s more of a surprise when the killer
ends up being right in front of him,
just another example of this movie’s
mission to do the unexpected.
That also includes the film’s ending. We are led
to believe that it will end at the
party, just like the original, but…
– This is what the reboots do,
they one-up the original ending.
– The Woodsboro Murders ended
at a party. So in the remake…
– The party’s the false ending. New rules.
– However, this also ends up being a false
ending, the true ending takes place at
the hospital. Just as there were two false
openings, there are also two false endings.
This is also something that happens in
the Halloween remake. The original ends
at the Doyle house, but the remake
continues on and ends at the Myers
house. There are probably other examples
of remakes in the 2000s doing this though.
So in this case, we have the quote unquote
remake continuing on past the original. Whereas,
in the 90s, if you wanted to continue past
the original, you had to watch Scream 2,
which contains a scene of a character
named Cici watching the movie Nosferatu,
and getting killed shortly after. For this
reason, I find it fitting that Kirby’s room
displays a Nosferatu poster, but who knows if
there was any actual meaning behind this choice,
it’s kind of a stretch on my
part to make that connection.
However, I am convinced that the wardrobe
choices were definitely done for a reason.
I talked before about how each character
in Scre4m represents one of the characters
from Scream. However, after the reveal of the
killers, all of those roles are reassigned.
Jill is now Billy, the mastermind behind
the murders. Charlie is still Stu,
the accomplice hoping to vent his
romantic frustrations with a knife.
Trevor is now Neil Prescott, the tied
up victim who is going to be framed.
So it’s no mistake that Jill is wearing a
blue plaid shirt, just like what Billy wore
at the party, and Trevor is wearing this exact
outfit that Neil was captured in back in 1996.
Other callbacks include Sidney escaping off the
roof, Charlie being tied to a chair like Steve
Orth, Kirby being quizzed on horror movies like
Casey Becker, and of course, this iconic line.
– Hello Sidney. Surprised?
– Surprise, Sidney.
– I imagine she’s getting tired of
hearing that. In my personal opinion,
Scre4m was one of the more
satisfying surprises though,
which makes all the clues about the
killers’ identities all the more impressive.
(upbeat music)
Upon rewatching the movie, I noticed that
while Jill and Charlie pretend they aren’t
particularly close, they do sit next to each
other in class, and Jill is the only one not
to take out her phone when everyone is
getting alerts about Jenny and Marnie,
though I’m not sure why she doesn’t
at least pretend to be interested.
On a somewhat related note, fellow Zac
and fellow horror creator Zack Cherry
pointed out in his video that Sidney doesn’t
appear to have a cell phone in this movie.
She receives calls on Jill’s cell and on
the Roberts’ landline, and after arriving
at Kirby’s she borrows Jill’s phone to place
an outgoing call to Dewey to plea for help.
This is probably because Sidney is tired
of all the prank calls and doesn’t want to
give any future copycat killers a means
of contacting her, it’s a nice touch.
Mr. Cherry also attributes a lot of the kills
to Charlie, which many were surprised by,
but I personally think it kind of makes
sense. Jill would have wanted to set it
up that way because of the fact that they’re
recording all of the kills and the fact that
she’s secretly planning to frame Charlie
as the one of the killers alongside Trevor.
It stands to reason that the police
would probably study these videos,
and take note of the killer’s
height and broad shoulders.
Charlie might also be the most forceful
Ghostface we’ve seen. Check this out.
(woman wimpering)
When I analyzed Scream 1, I mentioned that the
poster in Stu’s room matched a poster displayed
in the video store, and that this linked his
character to the movie obsessed killer. A similar
tactic is used here. Jill’s room is filled with
clues. This Farewell Republic poster and this…
uhh, I don’t know, reverse Griffon?... are
both posters seen hanging in the Cinema Club.
I will mention the possibility that there
is actually no meaning behind that. They
could have just reused posters and hoped
nobody would notice. Because this War of
The Worlds poster in Jill’s room also shows
up in her English class. I can’t think of any
reason they’d want to link Jill to her English
classroom. So it’s very possible that the art
department just ran out of posters and I’m
just looking for things that aren’t there.
But at the very least, we can conclude that
Jill is more interested in horror movies
and serial killers than she likes to let on,
from her American Werewolf in London poster,
to her Edgar Allan Poe-ster, to her Gale Weathers
books, books on psychology and serial killers and
even her Fall Out Boy poster; this particular one
is the cover for their single I Don’t Care, whose
chorus matches her MO for the movie. “I. Don’t.
Care what you think. As long as it’s about me.”
This might be more happenstance, but this
is also off their album Folie a Deux,
which is French for madness in pairs, a
term that could probably be used to describe
each pair of Ghostface killers. I love this
album, and I’d love to talk more about it,
but this is not a music analysis
channel, so let’s get back to Scre4m.
After Olivia is killed, Charlie comes out
of the dark to attack Sidney and Jill,
and Jill receives a cut on her forearm,
the same spot Derek got cut in Scream 2.
– No struggle? He just cut you and ran away?
You’re lucky he didn’t kill you.
– Yeah, it’s awfully convenient.
– Say what?
– Nothing,
it’s just a shame he got away so easily.
– It’s just a shame you got there too late!
– Of course, Derek ended up not being guilty,
so Dewey would probably want to avoid
making any similar accusation about Jill.
When Sidney speaks to Jill the following night,
she has what she thinks is a
bonding moment with her cousin.
– [Sidney] You know when people say, ‘I
know how you feel’, but they’re really just
saying that because they have no freaking
idea how you feel? I know how you feel.
– I love that line, because in reality,
Sidney has no idea how Jill feels because
she doesn’t suspect her of being the killer.
It’s like the sticker on the door of the
Cinema Club says: Not your usual suspects.
Jill claims she could never handle the attention
of being the surviving victim, when in fact,
that’s exactly what she wants, even if her
15 minutes of fame really is only 15 minutes.
And finally, at Kirby’s afterparty,
Trevor shows up unexpectedly, and
just walks right in because the door is unlocked.
– [Trevor] By the way Kirby, with everything
that’s going on right now, you probably shouldn’t
leave that unlocked.
– [Charlie] Sorry.
Charlie is not worried about locking
the door because he knows there’s no
threat. He and Jill are both in the room already.
Scre4m would be the final legacy of director
Wes Craven, but his creation would live on
without him after yet another 11 year gap
with Scream (2022). I’ll be covering it
next time on Things You Missed so make sure you
subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every week,
ring the deathbell for all notifications and
I’ll see you then. Assuming we both survive.